17 years ago in America evil had a name
and that name was al-qaeda the United
States of America is an enemy of those
who aid terrorists and of the barbaric
criminals who profane a great religion
by committing murder in his name but
that was 17 years ago in more recent
days things just aren't as clear-cut in
syria's in Lib Province the terrorist
group known as hayaat Tahrir al sham
previously known as al Qaeda in Syria is
alive and kicking now the UN's special
envoy for Syria Staffan de Mistura says
that over 10,000 Al qaeda-linked
fighters are in the area for a long time
the USA is promised that it will
separate the moderate opposition from
the designated terrorist groups but this
separation just hasn't happened and at
this point it seems like US officials
are focused on raising the alarm about
the Syrian government's efforts to
retake rebel-held territories President
Bashar Assad of Syria must not
recklessly attack adlet province in fact
the Trump administration has already
made it clear that if indeed there is a
chemical attack they already know who
did it if there are chemical weapons
that are used we know exactly who's
going to use them John Bolton Trump's
national security adviser says that the
idea that anybody with the Syrian
government might use chemical weapons is
just crazy it's just another example the
government of Russia and others have
said that we are giving the
authorization for al Qaeda to use
chemical weapons and try and pin it on
the government of Syria one of the most
outrageous claims that that I can think
of ultimately if Syria is put back
together this is the perfect kind of
example of a case where the people of
Syria themselves are going to have to
confront what governments did what their
government did purportedly in their name
so apparently I'll kind of brought down
the twin towers but they're just not
evil enough to release some chlorine gas
now the UN Special Envoy disagrees and
says that the terrorists are very
capable of conducting chemical attacks
the government on one hand
and al-nusra which is an organization
declared terrorist by the Security
Council are having the capability to
produce weaponized chlorine it quickly
stopped being a war about democracy
let's put it that way so there is no
distinction and I think the United
States News knows this it didn't matter
to the United States who won so long as
Assad lost the Americans are looking for
a way to stop the Syrian and Russian
advance on Italy and prevent this
conflict from being over the Syrian
government will will be responsible for
chemical attacks regardless of who does
them this isn't the first time that US
foreign policy has zigzagged when it
comes to al Qaeda back in the 1980s they
called Osama bin Laden a freedom fighter
when he was battling against the
Democratic Republic of Afghanistan CIA
gave him guns and US media cheered him
on it seems now u.s. foreign policy
regarding the al Qaeda terrorists has
gone full circle Kaleb Maupin RT New
York
you